Tyler Perry versus Kenya Barris or
whatever next week what is the argument
next week I want you to watch I'm not
gonna watch it I've already put my you
know I'm not gonna watch it but I like
the argument and I'll have the
discussion now Kenya Barris is the guy
who made black-ish brownish all the
airshows Tyler Perry is the guy who made
Tyler Perry studios based off of the
millions and millions of dollars she's
made off of Madea and all the other like
movies on television shows that he's
made and the argument is that Kenya
Barris is making television for white
people to indulge in black culture and
Tyler Perry makes television and movies
for black people to indulge in their own
culture is that more or less it's pretty
good the other thing and so what what is
the what is the discussion another layer
to it is that um black people can't
speak out negatively about other black
art because we have very little
opportunities in Hollywood so if you
knock black art that's correct it lowers
our chances of more opportunities but
the downside to that is by not knocking
the [ __ ] that's wack then you're never
gonna [ __ ] you want exactly and we'll
create wack [ __ ] another side to that is
that white people can't say anything bad
about black art also so you'll have like
a black movie won't mention names and
then I'll have a 99
rotten tomato get out like it's the best
thing that's ever been created right but
it wasn't that [ __ ] revolutionary but
it's just because if a white person
comes out and says oh this movie wasn't
that good now it's like oh you're just
not gonna because which one was get out
was that the one double side down one
[Music]
they kidnapped the black people and turn
them into in the white people that's the
movie about Jordan peels life that was
snuffer wiser that's Jordan
every time he's been attracted to a
woman what so whinnies Jordan people
making a movie about how awful white
women are well only dating and marrying
a white boy isn't projecting Sunday but
yeah for me I don't think there's
anything revolutionary but there
it's separate website that is existed
yeah they got 99 on Rotten Tomatoes come
no that's a great point say that white
people are not allowed to criticize
minority art because out of fear like it
would be perceived as racist that's why
any the female Ghostbusters got like an
85 percent from the critics on Rotten
Tomatoes everybody okay I think these
are men the same thing with the Asian
movie what was it son Oh crazy rich
Asians not a good movie not a good movie
but white people like oh I love crazy
when the net and then the Chappelle
special was in verse yeah we're like rod
tomatoes was trash on it but audience
rating was too bright so his Chappelle
transcended his blackness now repeal is
just a he because Chappelle is going at
quote-unquote like the lesser minorities
are like people who are more minorities
than black people right other strands
whatever I understand why the the
criticism might be is not going along
with like the way Hollywood you know
sets up its ideals but why is he
criticizes a bull just by his blackness
and I think it's because he's
transcended his blackness I think
Chappelle has just become Chappelle not
black comic Chapelle let me just make
the point and so it's like once he's
become that now you could criticize him
if his opinions are not inlined
because the argument that they're making
right now is you can't criticize black
art because of blackness not because of
the opinion within the art yeah right so
Chappelle is was highly criticized and
he was knocked for his special because
he went after these groups but maybe
he's transcended his blackness so that
you can't criticize him where you
couldn't do that with somebody else I
think there's like a like unspoken
hierarchy like minorities within like
liberal white people's mind right so
when Tracy Morgan says some [ __ ] that's
not a good joke but he's like if I have
a gay son I'm gonna kill them whatever
yeah oh you're a black person but you're
going at gay people they are more
minority or whatever however whatever
the word is they're like they're more
oppressed so you can't say that it's
just you can't punch down as this ideal
that's been beaten into their minds and
if they feel like you are punching down
to a more oppressed minority then
whoever you are it's not okay so to the
Chappelle point those white people that
were being critical of Tracy
they see him as tracy Jordan from 30
rock those are the same white people
that watched 30 rock those are same
white people that have maybe propped up
Tracy Morgan to be this character and
all of a sudden that character character
was saying things that didn't align with
who his character wasn't a show
I think there's I mean this is a slur so
it's different and I'm just trying to
think of whatever examples pop into my
head at the moment like they hear the
same rappers say like those white people
will not criticize a jay-z or they'll
criticize like any rapper for saying you
know homophobic lyrics this that the
other I think they're only willing to
come at the people who've kind of
transcended their blackness in a way who
became these like family names and like
rap is hard because I think there's like
a weird why people are so afraid to talk
anything about rap that they let them
get away with stuff they would never let
a comic get away with their rap is like
its own like why people are scared to
even delve into those waters of what's
offensive lyrics and what's not right
but if a rapper said some [ __ ] not on a
rap song that was homophobic or whatever
I think they'd be out yo you can't say
that you know what I mean like if they
say something on their social media or
whatever the case is people come for but
they say that same thing in a song it's
like oh for some reason it's untouchable
it's untouched yeah yeah maybe yeah it
is interesting I don't know I don't know
like I don't know
I just feel it like it's like a weird
unspoken thing that everybody just
abides by which is all the things that I
listened before like why people can't
knock black art black people can only
show appreciation for other black art or
now but they did before up until like a
year and a half ago black we used to
[ __ ] on everything Tyler Perry like if
you were woke black at all you would
[ __ ] on all Tyler Perry I remember red
tails coming out years ago
and all my life what black friends are
like yo don't watch I'm a deal movie I
come around the same time they're like
don't watch that [ __ ] watch red tails
you know that's a movie about black
people red tails is like a Steven
Spielberg movie you're just giving money
back to a white guy Tyler Perry that's
trash don't go see that that's going
back into a black person's pocket who
has a black studio in Atlanta but
somehow that's not cool to you and then
Twitter just caught on to what Tyler
Perry does so I I wouldn't say vocalize
it publicly but I used to think on that
same sentiment and I was like
I don't like Tyler Perry films because
like the characters in there are very
stereotypical and like not Kunis but
like like dance you know in the extra
hood extra all the negative con con
nations whatever that word is that
associated with black people but then we
felt that oh ok if he gets popularity
with making those movies and those are
gonna be the only roles for black people
that's why we knocked that [ __ ] because
like I can still watch it on Perry film
and laugh at it but Madea is a hilarious
camping object I'm hoping that that's
not the only movies I'm gonna see yeah
but you know what helps is black movies
doing well and also the people I know
that like Tyler Perry movies were black
so if my market like if my people like
this who am I to shame them for liking
anything we put out like I hear people
try to say Russell Peters is like
offensive because he makes accent
Indians I know growing up we all loved
Russell so if he's making [ __ ] for us
who the [ __ ] are you to tell him he's
wrong or us we're wrong for liking
someone that looks like us doing stuff
that makes us laugh yeah that's why I
don't understand like the woking side
definitely my switch side since like you
know I appreciate what I like and I
knock what I don't is tyler criticized
by southern blacks as strongly as he's
criticized by like i think you don't
like what depending the low blacks
kind of exist in like new york and
california are more here they're there
but they're more still right yeah i'm
just curious because maybe they're black
maybe their life within blackness is not
relatable to what tyler talks about and
maybe the characters that tyler talks
about seem cartoonish to these like new
york and california blacks but maybe
they're like really relatable to figures
in their lives to the southern blacks
like maybe they have an uncle that's
like they have an aunt to have a big
mama you know they have these people
that operate really similarly and
they're like this isn't that crazy
you think it's cartoonish but to us it's
not like yeah that duck dynasty show i
bet in new york in california white
people like guys a bunch of hillbillies
i bet if you go
Souths it's like now I got an uncle that
wears was it called army fatigues or
whatever that [ __ ] is mm-hmm forgot to
go
where's army fatigues or whatever every
single day just like that hmm so I
wonder if it's just a lack of
relatability and one of the problems
with like looking at blackness as a
monolith like looking at one type of
blackness and then when you don't live
up to that type of blackness you're like
oh yeah this doesn't make sense I think
the most interesting thing about like
the black is show or like the Tyler
Perry show etc is it I think oftentimes
the way that people appreciate things
are when they live up to your view of
them hmm right so it's like maybe the
people that appreciate the Tyler Perry
movies they're going oh yeah this is how
I see black people and maybe the people
that appreciate the black it shows like
oh this is how I see black people mm-hmm
I think that's where what black people
get a friend of those they think why
people look at black people like Madea
yeah and that's the thing it's like
white people aren't watching Madea white
people are watching blackish right cuz
they maybe that's closer to how they see
bi people they're like okay I see black
people existing in these white spaces
and I see them acting quote-unquote
black within these white spaces but I
also don't see them being like a
stereotype that Madea would be that'd be
a little too far-fetched if anything I'd
feel a little bit guilty enjoying that
because it's like is there some sort of
uh you know leaning into like the
extreme of a cultural stereotype yeah
something I was afraid of happening was
that Hollywood would see the success of
Madea movies and be like oh let's make
our own yeah that's what I was worried
about that was my biggest issue I was
like oh no I mean Mama's house I mean
Big Momma's House is Madea wasn't
popping when Big Momma's House okay yeah
I think I might have been plays I think
that she started his plays I don't meet
the brown star displays like this
[ __ ] is a monster plays two
movies to TV shows creative genius and
business exec now he's a beast in yeah
[ __ ] changed in terms of perception of
Tyler Perry when he built his own studio
hung up second you see that studio
people like [ __ ] I might have to put on
one em [ __ ] costume even when he had
it at first though and all of a sudden
he
had to literally just start doing some
Oprah [ __ ] I mean like your Walmart
everything I got on layaway I'm paying
for it like II that's what it took
people will be like oh Tyler Perry's
doing it but it is really funny is like
you don't you do need a show you can't
just tell right like it was this common
thing you'd hear like a lot of like
black entertainers saying like I'm not
gonna put on a dress and I think like
Dave Chappelle got it in people's heads
it like that's what the Hollywood
industry tries to make you do is put on
a dress they want to emasculate black
men I don't think it was about a
masculine black man I think it there is
you could add racism into it by going
what's funny or commit juxtapositions so
what is the most masculine thing some
nerdy exec sees probably the black male
and then what is funny to some corny
exec is seeing the most masculine thing
look feminine right today you're in a
dress sounds funny Schwartz and a dress
can't even knock it right michael cera
and a dress not funny there was actually
a Motorsports inator got pregnant he out
of the your dresses and [ __ ] yeah
there's a movie where he got pregnant so
we're seeing mr. Olympia whatever that
[ __ ] is mr. universe dressed as a girl
right we're pregnant as a girl there's a
communication jocks position there now
you there's an element of race and
everything you could go why do they see
black males as this hyper masculine
thing that would be funny if you made
them feminine okay maybe you look at
black males and a little bit different
like maybe a little scared maybe or
whatever there you go that's and that is
your what is it called bias
yeah subconscious bias yeah or something
you know that is that subconscious bias
that they have but I don't think it's as
simple as there was a meeting where a
bunch of execs were like hey why don't
we get black people to wear wigs and
dresses that'll be fun yeah well
emasculate all the blacks like that yeah
I don't think it's happening and then I
think they touch on that too cuz they're
like look at that was a movie uh Tootsie
in 1982 where I don't know Michael
Dorsey some guy he dressed up like a
girl and then you have of course what's
mrs. Doubtfire like it's been done Mike
it's the corniest version of comedy it's
like what if you look at Instagram
comedians right not to knock them but
like what is the first thing they go to
when they're trying to make a funny skit
someone who doesn't really have any like
comedy writing skill what do they do
they throw a [ __ ] wig on they throw a
dress this is how girls act right it is
the lowest common denominator of joke
right like back in the day every comic
would just do a gay voice as a joke yeah
and it was hilarious
because it's a person who you do not see
as gay acting gay mm-hmm right it's just
the easiest way to make a joke if we're
making fun of each other we're gonna do
it in an emasculating way this is what
happens in a locker room just a funny
thing to do but it is interesting
discussion is cool to see them talk
about I'd love to see them do it out of
a scripted like I'd love to see them
have a podcast about it mm-hm and maybe
both of those things are important maybe
there's like a Martin Malcolm thing
there it's like hey I need to do this
for us the Malcolm approach yeah of it
and then that scene really felt like
that it felt like that Martin was like I
know you need to do that but I also need
to make sure there's an integration play
as well so it's like we should watch
this episode guys have some valuable
here
[Applause]